ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูป๊าสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนหวัดดีค่ะนักเรียนอีกสวัสดี
ค่ะต้อนรับค่ะสูตรคอมพลีเห็นสิบ่ไทยใช้ขา
ในบีกินเนอร์ 4 นะคะดีนะ 4 เหรอมีได้แล้ว
ค่ะเช้านี้ที่เราคุยกันอยู่วันอะไรคะครู
ป่าวันนี้วันพุธค่ะคือโอเรียมวันพุธวัน
พุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพุธที่
17 เดือนอะไรคะดีแลนสิงหาคมค่ะ
ปีพศอะไรคะปีพต 2  565
แล้วปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะหรือยังกี่
โมงแล้วค่ะครูป๋าตอนพรุ่งนี้
10:00 น 57 นาทีน 57 นาทีน
o.k. ลู่ฟ้าก็ยังไม่กินข้าวใช่ไหมคะ
ว่ายังไม่ได้กินข้าวเลยค่ะบุเรียนมที่บาย
ให้หิวแล้วใช่ไหมหิวแล้วค่ะอยู่แล้ว
เดี๋ยว
พูดใช่ไหมสอนนักเรียนเสร็จก็จะไปกินข้าว
นะคะ
คุณกินข้าวหรือยังเตรียมยังไม่กินข้าวค่ะ
กินขนมยิ่งที่ขนมรีบคิดว่าครูฟ้ามีความอด
ทนมากเลยนะทำไมฮะคือแบบยังไม่กินข้าวเช้า
เลยอ่ะแล้วครูฟ้าก็หิวมากแล้วด้วยใช่หา
นักเรียนกุมภาเนี่ยยังไม่ได้กินข้าวนะคะ
ตอนเช้าก็ยังไม่ได้กินมาก็เลยอดทน
หิวแต่ว่าอดทนได้กูก็โอเคนะกดทนนท์มีอะไร
ค่ะครูฟ้าเรียนกินแทนครูฟ้าก็ได้เรียนนี้
ขนมอยู่ตอนเนี้ย
ใช่อย่างนี้ขนมอยู่อ่ะกูขาดผู้เลี้ยงว่า
ควรจะเรียนจะกินโชว์ใช่ไหมคะกินแทนภูฟ้า
ไงให้ครูฟ้าแบบรู้สึกดีขึ้นรู้สึกวิธี
ทำไม่เป็นไรค่ะครัวอดทนได้เหลี่ยมขอทุน
ใช่อุบาทว์ทำให้เรียมนึกถึงคนคนหนึ่งที่
มีความอดทนแบบเยอะมากๆถึงหรอใครอ่ะ
กูฟ้ารู้จักเคยได้ยินชื่อพระเตมีย์มั้ยคะ
พระเตมีย์ไม่เคยได้ยินเลยค่ะโคเรียมไม่
เคยได้ยินไม่รู้จักหรอเขาเป็นใครคะพระเต
มีย์เนี่ยเป็นลูกของพระราชา
รู้ของพระราชามีแต่ว่าพระเตมีย์เป็นเจ้า
ชายใช่คะใช่ค่ะเป็นเจ้าชายยิ้มพ่อกับแม่
รักมากๆ
โอ้โหเป็นลูกรักด้วยนะใช่ไหมต้องบอกว่า
พระราชาเนี่ยก็จะมีภรรยานะคะภรรยาภรรยาก็
จะเป็นพระราชินีราชินี
ๆค่ะตอนแรกอ่ะไม่ได้มีพระเตมีย์นะพระราชา
กับพระราชินี
อยากมีลูกมากๆเอางูก่อนที่จะมีพระเตมีย์
เนี่ยพระราชากับพระราชินีก็ไม่มีลูกหรอกู
เหนียงไม่มีลูกเลยค่ะแล้วก็อยากมีลูกมากๆ
ยังไงอ่ะอยากมีลูกแต่ไม่มี
ไม่มีใช่ราชาก็เลยแบบมีมีเขาเรียกอะไรนะ
มีภรรยาหรือว่ามีเมียอีกหลายๆคนอ๋อ
เพราะว่าตอนแรกเนี่ยพระราชาแต่งงานแทนแทน
เพื่อนๆเกี่ยวกับพระราชินีใช่ไหมคนที่ 1
แต่ไม่มีลูก
ก็เลยพระราชาก็เลยต้องไปหาผู้หญิงเอามา
เป็นภรรยา
เพื่อที่จะมีรุ่นใช่ไหมคะใช่แต่ว่าสมัย
ก่อนผ่าพระราชทานมีภรรยาหลายคนที่ก็ก็ไม่
เป็นไรนะอื้มเอาว่าจะมีแบบคนคนนึงอ่ะที่
เป็นแบบเขาเรียกว่าอะไรนะสำคัญที่สุดอ่ะ
พระราชินี
ใช่เพราะว่าจริงๆพระราชินีเนี่ยคนที่ 1
เนี่ยต้องเป็นพระราชินีเนาะส่วนภรรยาคน
ที่ 2  3  4  5  6 เนี่ยจะไม่ใช่พระ
ราชินีนะจะเป็นภรรยาใช่แต่ถ้าเกิดมีลูกนะ
ก็ดีนะเธอฉันพระราชาก็จะดีใจช่วงราชา
เนี่ยเขามีแบบสมบัติเยอะมีเงินมีเนินมี
แล้วแทนสร้อยมีเยอะมากพระราชาต้องรวยรวย
หัวหน้ารวยค่ะถ้าเกิดไม่มีลูกเหรอคะครู
ฟ้าวันนึงตายไปสมบัติที่เป็นแหวนเป็น
สร้อยเป็นเงินน่ะจะเอาให้ใคร
จะเอาให้ใครนั่นน่ะสิไม่ได้แล้วคุณเรียม
ต้องมีลูกค่ะได้เอาให้ครูฟ้าได้ไหมต้อง
พูดว่าเป็นใครอ่ะไม่ใช่ลูกไงว่าไม่ใช่ลูก
เหรอพระราชาไม่ให้ครูฟ้าหรอกไม่ให้แหละ
มึงมาช้าก็เลยบอกบอกภรรยาทุกคนว่าต้องมี
ลูกต้องมีลูกให้ได้
แล้วเป็นยังไง
แล้วก็ภรรยาอีกคนที่ 2  3  4  5 ก็ไปไหว้
ไหว้แล้วก็ขอขอลูกขอให้ง้อ
ไปไหว้กับเทพเจ้าใช่ไหมหรือว่ากอล์ฟนะฮะ
ขอให้ท้องขอให้มีลูกเนอะอย่าลืมขอพรไหว้
แต่ก่อนแต่ว่าพระราชินีพระราชินีไม่ได้ขอ
พรนะพระราชินีก็บอกว่าพระราชินีจะทำความ
ดี
ทำความดีทำอะไรอยู่เรียนรักษาศีลถ้าเกิด
เป็นคนไทยในศาสนาพุทธนะก็จะมีศีล 5
คือสัตว์ใช่มั้ยในฆ่าสัตว์ใช่อ่ะไม่ฆ่า
สัตว์ไม่ฆ่าหมาแมวไม่ตบยุง
ชายแล้วก็ไม่ไม่รักขโมยไม่ขโมยอุ๊ยเครียม
มีนาฬิกาสวยโครงฟ้าไปขโมยมาดีกว่าไม่ได้
พระราชินีไม่ทำไม่ลักขโมยแล้ว 3 เลยนะไม่
เหอะไม่โกหกใช่ไหมไม่โกหกไม่โกหกโกหกก็
คือพูดไม่จริงนะพูดไม่จริงพูดไม่ดีเนี่ย
เขา 3 ไม่โกหกใช่แล้วข้อ 4 ก็คือก็ไม่ไม่
ประพฤติผิดในการก็คือรักคะราชาคนเดียวใช่
ก็คือไม่ไปเอ่อไม่ไปชอบภรรยาคนอื่นไม่ไป
รักสามีคนอื่นรับสามีของเรารับภรรยาของ
เราคนเดียวอันนี้ข้อสิ่งเราก็ข้อที่ 5 ก็
คือไม่ดื่มแอลกอฮอล์
ทายไม่ดื่มไม่เด็ดขาดไม่ได้ค่ะอื้อใช่ว่า
ราชินีก็บอกว่าจะทำความดีหาข้อนี้ๆหาพระ
ราชินีก็ทำความดีไปเรื่อยๆจนวันหนึ่งพระ
ราชนีท้องช่อพระราชินีท้องแล้วหรอคะนี่
ลูกมีรูปแล้ว
ดีใจไหมดีใจมากค่ะมีแล้วเป็นยังไงพระราชา
ก็รักใช่ไหมคะรักมากแล้วลูกคนนั้นแหละลูก
ของพระราชินีคนนะและก็คือพระตีมีที่เรียน
พูดถึงตั้งเป็นชื่อของเขาและเขาชื่นพระเต
มีย์
ใช่ค่ะนั่นแหละพ่อแม่รักมากเกิดขึ้นมา
เนี่ย
เขาก็เลยแบบดูแลอย่างดีอยู่ไหนอย่างดีนะ
พ่อแม่รักเธอแล้วเป็นยังไงหาเตมีย์ก็จะ
เป็นเด็กดีใช่ไหมๆค่ะเป็นเด็กดีเป็นเด็ก
ที่แบบฉลาดมากเนื้อ
IQ  285 ฉลาด
ลาดมากไอ้คิวกับ EQ ดีแต่ว่าวันหนึ่งอายุ
ประมาณ 4 ขวบ
อายุ 4 ขวดเกิดอะไรขึ้นคะครูเรียมคะราชา
เนี่ยรักลูกมากอุ้มลูกอุ้มพระเตมีย์ไป
ด้วยพระเตมีย์อายุ 4 ขวบค่ะเราก็ข้า
ราชการเนี่ยต้องไปแบบลงโทษโจนส์
ว่ามันจะจูนก็คือคนที่ขโมยเงินนะคะใช่
มั้ยคือริบฉันที่แอบขโมยเงินเออโดนเนี่ย
เป็นคนไม่ดีในเมื่อโจรมาขโมยเงินของพระ
ราชาพระราชาก็ต้องลงโทษ
เฮ้ย
ในขณะที่พระราชาองค์พระเตมีย์อยู่พระราชา
ก็ให้คนฆ่าโจรประมาณ 5 คนหรือเปล่าประมาณ
4 หรือ 5 คนนี่แหละก็คือมีโจร 5 คนเลย
เหรอคะชาลี 5 คนแล้วก็แบบข้าข้าโจรทั้ง 5
คนเมื่อก่อนนะเนาะถ้าเกิดโจรมาขโมยเงิน
พระราชาขโมย
สร้อยพระราชาขโมยแหวนพระราชาเนี่ยเขาจะลง
โทษด้วยการฆ่า
ใช่ว่าคนโชว์ลูกเลยหรอใช่กูยังคิดอยู่
อุ้มลูก 4 ขวบ 4 เครื่องอ๊อดสั่งฆ่าแล้ว
ก็ค่าให้ลูกเห็น
เป็นยังไงอ่ะพระเตมีย์กลัวไหมคะลูกค้า
อ้างอิงว่าเนี่ยตัดผ้าได้มีเก่งนะเพราะจะ
มีรู้ว่าอ๋อพ่อของตัวเองเนี่ยเป็นพระราชา
พระราชาต้องทำแบบนี้เวลามีคนทำไม่ดี
เมื่อเช้าต้องเป็นคนบอกว่าจะโอเคไหมหรือ
ไม่โอเคหรือว่าข้าพระราชาจะเป็นคนบอกมึง
แต่ภาพที่มีก็รู้ไงดีแล้วเขาก็เรียนให้มา
แต่มีก็เลยรู้สึกว่า
ถ้าโตขึ้นไป
เป็นลูกพระราชาณวัดนึงฮะแต่มีต้องเป็นพระ
ราชา
แล้วก็ต้องสั่งฆ่าคนอื่นเหมือนที่พ่อทำ
แล้วก็ไปมีโอเคหรอคุณเรียมให้มีไม่อยากทำ
ถ้าไม่อยากทำทำยังไงอ่ะใช่เขาจะมีก็เลยตก
ใจมากแล้วพอพระได้มีกลับไปนอนค่ะว่าจะมี
ก็ฝัน
ฉันว่าอะไรคะคุณเหลี่ยมฝันว่าพระเตมีย์
เคยเกิดเป็นพระราชา
นานมาแล้วนานวันนอกฝันว่าตัวเองเนี่ยนะ
พระเตมีย์ฝันว่าตัวเองเคยเป็นพระราชา
เมื่อก่อนใช่มั้ยเป็นความฝันนะร้องแล้วก็
สั่งแบบข้าให้ข้าคน
สะพัดจะมีไม่อยากฆ่าคนในความฝันเนี่ยก็
ฝันว่าตัวเองฆ่าคนฆ่าคนห้าคนมากๆ
ยังไงเค้าพูดแล้วพ่อข้าคนในตอนนั้นน่ะถ้า
จะมีต้องไปอยู่ในนรก
คือก็คือว่ามันเป็นแบบพูดอะเนาะศาสนาพุทธ
นะก็จะมีนรกมีสวรรค์ชั้นได้หักเรียนจะ
ร้องก็จะมีไฟเยอะๆนรกนี่คือคนที่ทำไม่ดี
คนทำไม่ดีถ้าตายแล้วจะต้องไปนรกไปณรงค์
ใช่ไปนรกนรกนรกที่มีไฟ
ร้อนร้อนๆๆถ้าเป็นแบบโรมันกรีกน่ะจะมี
ก็อดที่อยู่ในนรกคือเฮเดสสหกรณ์ hadis
นั่นแหละคือนรกคนทำไม่ดีถ้าโตมีต้องไปนรก
เหรอเค้าเรียมให้ไปอยู่นรก 8 หมื่นปี
แรกหมื่นปี
ใช่
ไม่ไหวไม่โอเคเลยอย่างนี้ทำยังไงไม่อยาก
ให้ถ้ากูไม่ทำยังไงดี
ถ้าโตขึ้นไปไปเป็นพระราชาอีกก็ต้องฆ่าคน
อื่นพัฒนีไม่อยากไปอยู่ในนรก 8 หมื่นปี
ยังไงดีล่ะ
คะเต้นมีฝันอยู่ก็เลยมีนางฟ้าคนนึง
ใจฟ้านะเดี๋ยวว่านั่งปลาไหมตุ้ยปีดวิกา
ชายที่มีปีก
นางฟ้ามาก็ไม่บอกพระเตมีย์มาว่า
ไม่เป็นไรไม่ต้องกลัว
ทำยังไงล่ะถ้าไม่อยากเป็นพระราชา
ก็ทำเป็นง่อย
เป็นง่อยอ๋อ
ตอนนี้เราปกติใช่ครูเรียนเรามีมือดีนิ้ว
มือปกติแต่คนที่เป็นง่อยเนี่ยเป็นง่อยคือ
มือเป็นอย่างนี้เนาะใช้มือไม่ได้ปากไป
เที่ยว
ชายๆรวมเป็นง่อยแบบที่ปากเบี้ยว
ทำยังไงสุขอันเดียวหรือว่ามือมือแบบนี้ก็
มีนะคนที่เป็นง่อยไทยหาบางคนก็เป็นว่า
อยากที่แบบ
มึงขายกูไม่ได้คือไม่ปกติอะปกติขยับตัว
ไม่ได้นอนนิ่งๆอยู่นิ่งๆคือให้พระเตมีย์
แกล้งเป็นง่อยแกล้งไม่ได้เป็นจริงๆเนาะ
ไม่ได้เป็นจริงๆแล้วบอกว่าแกล้งนะคะคือจะ
โกหกอ่ะการแรงเด็กน้อยระวังแกล้งหูหนวก
ไม่ได้ยินใช่คู่ฟ้าครูฟ้า
ฟ้า
ดินทุกคนหูหนวกใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะคือความจริง
ได้ยินอยู่แต่ว่าแบบคนที่หูหนวกจริงๆคือ
เขาจะแบบไม่ได้ยินไม่ได้
ก็แกล้งเป็นใบ้
เป็นใบ้คือคนที่พูดไม่ได้
คนที่พูดไม่ได้เนี่ยเราบอกว่าเป็นใบ้ปกติ
แล้วถ้าคนหูหนวกเขาจะเป็นใบ้ด้วยเนาะเป็น
ไม่มีก็จะไม่พูดแล้วก็แบบไม่ได้ยิน
หนู
เป็น 3 อย่างเลยค่ะหนูบ้างเปล่าแกล้งเป็น
ง่อย
แกล้งหนูหนวดแกล้งเป็นใบ้
ใช่พระเตมีย์ทำแบบนั้นโอเคไหมโอเคไหมที่
จะแสดงนี้ก็ถ้าแกล้งทำ 3 อย่างแล้วไม่
ต้องลงไปอยู่ในนรก 8 หมื่นปีพระเตมีย์จะ
อดทน
อุดทุนแปลงแป้งเป็นง่อยแกล้งเป็นใบ้แกล้ง
หูหนวกอือมันยากมากเลยเนาะ
ก็ทำอะไรไม่ได้เงี้ยทำอะไรไม่ได้เลยแล้ว
มันไม่มีใครรู้มาก่อนว่าพระเตมีย์จะเป็น
ง่อยหูหนวกเป็นใบ้
คนไม่เชื่อ
วันนึงเนี่ยคะจะมีเปลี่ยนไปแบบเป็นแบบ
เนี้ยก็ที่เมื่อก่อนฉลาดมากคือแล้วคนอื่น
ว่ายังไงกันคนอื่นพระราชาไม่เชื่อหรอไม่
เชื่อพระราชาก็เลยทำทุกอย่างเพื่อให้รู้
ว่าพระเตมีย์นไม่ได้เป็นใบ้ไม่ได้เป็น
ร้อยไม่ได้หูหนวก
ทำยังไงก็มีวิธีเช็คใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะมีวิธี
เช่นก็คือตอนเป็นเด็กน่ะเด็กเวลาแบบหิว
ใช่ไหมหิวต้องร้องไห้เออ
หิวแล้วหิวข้าวอยู่มืออะราชาก็เลยแบบไม่
ขอให้พระเตมีย์ดื่มนมหรือว่ากินนม
ไม่รอให้พระเตมีย์หิว
น่าจะมีจะได้ร้องไห้แล้วพัดจะมีร้องไห้
ไหมคะไม่
เอาที่มีอดทนให้มีหิวหน้าหิวแต่ว่าถ้า
เกิดร้องให้คนอื่นจะรู้
ว่าไม่ได้เป็นง่อยไม่ได้เป็นใบ้โง่จริง
มากเลยดิเธอกดทนใช่อดทนไม่กินข้าวไม่ร้อง
ไห้
พระราชาชื่อหรือยังไม่เชื่อ
แล้วก็พระราชาก็แบบใช้วิธีอื่นอีก
ใช้วิทยาลัยอีกข้างอายุช่วง
ช่วงประมาณเท่าไหร่นะมีช่วงหนึ่งที่คิด
ว่าเด็กๆจะชอบกินผลไม้ยิ้มแน่นเปิ้ล More
in กล้วยอะไรเงี้ย
อะราชาก็เอาผลไม้มาใกล้ๆ
เอามาให้พระเตมีย์เพราะคิดว่าเด็กชอบกิน
ผลไม้ถ้าเต็มที่ต้องเอามือมาหยิบผลไม้มา
กินแล้วพระเตมีย์หยิบผลไม้มากินไหมไม่ค่ะ
อดทนมากนะอุดทนมากอดทนหน้าเรามีเด็กๆพระ
ราชาคิดว่าเด็กๆชอบเล่นของเล่น
จะเอาของเล่นมาของเล่นก็คือหรือตอนนี้
เด็กๆก็จะเลโก้เนอะเลยค่อยเป็นของเล่นตา
ที่เธอจะทาบานที่ Safety มีอะไรเงี้ยของ
เล่นเอาของเล่นมาให้พระเตมีย์หรอคะคุณ
เรียมเอาของเล่นมาให้พระ thanee
เด็กชอบเล่นของเล่นพระราชาคิดแบบนั้นแล้ว
แต่มีก็อ่ะ
มีกิ่งไม่เสียบตัว
ไม่สนใจ
สิ่งมากแล้วอดทนแบบนี้จนทุกคนเชื่อใช่ไหม
คนเลี้ยงหมทุกคนก็แบบหูผ่านจนผ่านไปจนถึง
อายุ 14 ปีหน้าจะ 14 ปีในระหว่างนี้ก็คด
สอบหลายอย่างมาก
ก็มีกันทดสอบเช็คนะอย่างที่คุณเรียมบอก
ยังไม่เชื่อนะยังไม่เชื่อจนกับผ่านไปแต่
ละปีแต่ละปีจะละปีก็ยังไม่เชื่อเขาสอบคะ
แต่มีอยู่ตลอด
หนึ่งแล้ว
เป็นไงต่อแล้วมึงจับทดสอบด้วยเอาเอาอาหาร
อร่อยๆเหมือนที่เนียมให้ครูฟ้าดูเนี่ย
หนึ่งก็คู่ค้าหนูก็หิวน่ะสิเรียมก็หิวน้ำ
ต้องพูดออกมามั้ยว่าพี่หิวอยากกินแต่ถ้า
เป็นครูผู้ก็พูดเนี่ยกูก็ไม่อดทนแล้วแต่
ตั้งไหมเนี่ยหัวยุ่งกูฟ้าภูเขาไม่อดทนนะ
ว่ากินโอ้ยหิวแต่ถ้าตัวเองมีพระเตมีย์
เนี่ยอดทนมากแล้วก็ไม่ไม่พูดไม่กินไม่พูด
เพราะภาพได้มีคิดแบบตกนรก 8 หมื่นปีถ้า
เป็นพระราชา
แต่ว่า
มันเกิดอะไรขึ้นนะมันมี Season  2 ไหม
คือมิสโหมีความที่สุด 2 เยอะกว่านี้อีก
พระราชาชาติทดสอบพระเตมีย์หลายอย่างมาก
ที่ภูฟ้าได้ฟังน่ะแค่แบบนิดเดียวเองนะหือ
ใช่มันเล็กน้อยแต่ว่ามันต้องอีมากกว่านี้
นะที่พระราชาจะต้องทดสอบว่าเป็นมีว่าคะ
แต่มีเป็นใบ้จริงหรือเปล่าหนูหนวดจริง
หรือเปล่านี่เป็นง่อยจริงหรือเปล่าใช่ถ้า
เกิดครูป๊ากับนักเรียนได้ฟังต้องแบบให้
ตกใจทำไมอ่ะว่าพระราชาทดสอบพระเตมีย์แบบ
นี้เลยหรอทำกับลูกตัวเองแบบนี้เลยหรอ
สิคุณเรียมแต่ว่า
ตอนนี้เวลาเท่ากันแล้วใช่ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลาอะไรว่าคะเด้มีจะอดทนได้มาก
ขนาดไหนได้ค่ะได้เลยเรามาดูกันว่าเป็นยัง
ไงต่อนักเรียนใช่ค่ะ EP ส่ง 2 เนาะวีดีโอ
หน้าเนาะนี้งดลาแล้วก็ง่ายๆแล้วเธอเจอกัน
ใหม่วิดีโอหน้าใช่ค่ะมันมารอดูกันว่าจะ
เกิดอะไรขึ้นอีกได้ค่ะได้หรือโอนี้ต้องลา
ไปก่อนแล้วค่ะกลุ่มไปฮ่าๆๆไอ้ฟายสวัสดี
ค่ะอ่ะ